on tiger belly or back oh tiger belly
right now and uh let's ask me in uh
two days i am a people pleaser and i
will tell you i'm a yes man
it's funny because um people now um you
know tony
people are moving to um texas austin
austin and i'm kind of excited about it
i'm excited that people are moving
chavez ravine for life
you know i want to stay here but it
makes sense for people that
aren't from l.a right if they came to
l.a
for a dream or whatever and certain
things have changed around it it makes
sense that
they they're jumping to another state
but if you're from here and you're in
angelino
this [ __ ] lives in your blood i don't
care if we get burnt to a crisp my
[ __ ] forest fires
one from san diego i guess i is that l.a
no
well then i'm not i'm not i'm not an
angelino then kalala is for sure
but you're you know california like
california yeah
you know this is the first place i
landed from the philippines and i always
thought
that oh i could live anywhere i could
live but as i'm getting older i'm like
holy [ __ ] man like
la's dope i love it here i don't care
what anyone says any every
the perception is that like hollywood is
a la and it's not
it's not the kids that i grew up with
the people that i know the friendships
that i've made it has
nothing to do with the elites of
hollywood
yeah i love when kids come here and they
have this dream
or this idea about los angeles and it's
usually you know
the perception is based on what they've
seen through
the media or television and film and
whatnot right but then they drive by
like
you know western and santa monica right
and they go what the [ __ ] this is not
you know that's
la to me me too and i love it yeah i
love it i love the grime of l.a i love
the grime
on my weekends um pre-covered i'd go to
los cayejones
i'd eat there saturday morning and i
i've also tried
listen i i want to say i've i love all
the cities i've ever been to i really do
and there's
little bits of it like you know i like
the rain in portland you know
i like just the the trees in austin for
some reason i just kind of like
that you know i like um the flatness of
idaho
that was a stretch bro i love the
beautiful flatness of idaho
have you been to idaho yeah yeah in a
second i know
well jessica went to idaho like two
years ago and she was like dude
it is beautiful here no maybe not idaho
i'm talking about um where's
why is guys indiana what are you you're
talking about omaha omaha
it's flammable omaha omaha all that is
the most boring state to drive through
omaha's nebraska yeah it's pretty flat
oh it's just corn for
five hours but you know you have these
you know ideas about
especially when you go to a red state
and you think yourself like my brother
always goes
bob is texas scary because it's like a
lot of white people with cowboy hats
it's like
no dude that's what like international
people think of america i know it's like
the opposite of that it's like an asian
hub too i know it's like
so fun and the people are so the best
audiences i've ever played for is in
texas
the most wild you know the strip clubs
are
wild baby you know i love
myself from texas and you know when you
look at you know
like a political map you know it's red
or whatever
it's like i don't visit those areas
right
in the cities man it's [ __ ] great but
um
but throughout all my travels um i still
miss la everywhere i go even hawaii i
was just in hawaii
which is um hey what's up sleepers can i
take another really quick break to share
some of these amazing products with you
they did